Vladimir Putin landed at the medieval
bricassart fort Emmanuel macron summer
residence on the Mediterranean Sea
the French president said he hoped to
persuade the Russian leader to help in
fighting in eastern Ukraine
Makarov said Ukraine's new president
Vladimir's Lansky's promised in the
conflict a food fresh hope Russian
backed fighters and Ukrainian forces
have been at war since Russia annexed
Crimea in 2014 the choice is made by
president Solinsky I think really
changed the situation
Putin has spoken to him several times in
recent weeks and it's an opportunity for
us to revisit the situation to exchange
and prepare future meetings concerning
president szalinski and Chancellor
Merkel we hope for a new summit in the
Normandy format in the coming weeks the
two leaders seem to make progress on
Ukraine Putin told Makarov there was
cause for optimism but there was a
little common ground on Syria the
Russian leader rebuffed McClure's demand
that Syria's moscow-backed regime
stopped bombing the it'd lip region
there have been several attempts to
attack our minim airbase from the area
of Italy that's why we support the
efforts of the Syrian army to end
terrorist threats there the talks karmas
macron prepares to host leaders from the
group of seven nations including Donald
Trump the g7 was the g8 until Russia was
excluded over Crimea the timing of this
meeting just days before the g7 summit
is significant macro wants to highlight
france's ability to talk to all sides
and bolster his country standing on the
international stage and despite the
clear differences between Paris and
Moscow macro says it's important to keep
dialogue with Russia open Mankiller
heard coalition if you're about to do
you Jamie
even though Russia is not in the g8
today's g7 in a way it was never totally
excluded because political leaders
realized that they can't totally ignore
Russia's position as a world power
Micro's attempts to reach out to
President Putin could be a risk the
Russian leaders proved uncompromising in
the past but the French president hopes
his efforts could lead to brokering
peace in
crane and ending Europe's only war
natasha butler al jazeera PAGASA fought
france